goo
[音楽]
高校生の時自分はものづくりが好きで
工業高校に入りました
でバイクとかあと車とかが大好きだったので機械科に行ってエンジンの詳しいこととか
を学んで
で後まあ高校2年生の時
結構変わっていったんですけど友達と一緒に
福岡レゲエ魂という夏べ数
ok 入って不幸かレゲエ魂という
えっとレゲエフェスティバルに友達と遊びって
そしたら福岡のアーティスト後長崎のアーティストが地元の歌
ローカルソングを歌ってたのとあと友達の唄家族のうたを歌って
で会場をめちゃくちゃ盛り上げてたので
めちゃくちゃオジュンはこれにしようともう
自分の夢愛ミュージシャンだと思ってそこから色々と自分で作詞作曲もするし
あとちょっと人前で歌ってみたりもするしってことを挑戦していきました
そして高校3年生
えっと自分は畳家の長男ではあるんですけど全然もする気なくて
なので進学音楽学校に進学をするかもしくは就職をするかっていう風に悩んで
で自分は就職っていう選択肢をしたんですけど
就職をして働きながらやろうって決めました
音楽活動でそれで
旅といえばほんと古臭いので10全然興味なくて
それやったら伝統よりかは最先端のものに憧れてたので半導体関連メーカーに入社をし
たんです
そうなんですえっとほんとこれから led が出てくるとか
あとスマートフォンが普及してくるといわれて
ああ
時なのでな述べ
半導体関連メーカーがいいかなと思って色々と見てしかも東証一部上場だったので安泰
かなと思って入ったんですよね
でもなんか社会っていうのはなんか難しいなと思って
ちょうどその頃2009年リーマンショックなんですよね
その頃にリーマンショックがあって
なかなか時間も取れないしでまぁ新入社員ですけどお金がそんなにもらえないので
音楽にかける費用が全然なくて
ななんしよーかなーと思ってあと
先輩とか上司とかがよく言ってたんですけど
徳田口みたいな18歳のとき
あんなことしておけば良かったとかまぁ好きなことをしておけば守備とかもっと広げて
おけばよかったみたいに言ってたんですけどなんかその人たちを見てこんな大人には
なりたくないなぁって思ったんですよね
で
なりたくないだと思ったしあとを人生に悔いが残るのはもう絶対やなのでもう1年で
退職しますって
ジョーシン言ってそれやったらまあしゃあないねーみたいな
まあ言われてそれでその会社は1年で退職をしてその次に音楽学校に通いたいなぁと
思ったので
博多にあるボーカルスクールに通い始めました
でそれでえっと通うまでにはちょっとあって派遣会社に入って100万円という資金を
貯めてそれで入ろうと思ったので1年間頑張って派遣会社で働いて1年限定なので
100万円という目標で
ああああああ
目標を達成して200万円という目標を達成してそれでその資金のもと音楽学校に入り
ました
それから音楽学校に入ってライブ活動もしつつ
毎月大手レコード会社とか大手芸能事務所の
なんかオーディションがあるのでそれを受けたりあとライブかつをバンバンやってたん
ですけどなかなか上手くいかず
やっぱ
その芸能という壁は結構高いんだなぁと思って
で結構挫折をしてで悩んでたんですよね
でそれで
東京からくる
先生講師の先生がいてその人と
ミーティングする機会があって
ミーティング以前からお世話になってたので
自分は小学校の頃からずっと続けていることがあってお世話になった人に畳のし規模の
プレゼントをするっていうのを決めてるんですよね
なので今日もちょっと持ってきたんですけど
こういった畳の敷物をお世話になった人に感謝の気持ちであげるっていう事をやって
そしたらその先生自分がた度あってことを知らないのであなたタミヤなのっていうこと
で惹かれて入ったタミヤですってことを言ってなんであなた畳はならないのっていう
感じで言うんです
よね自分は本当
畳はこれから減っていくし
不動産の物件の賃貸によっても
畳の部屋がないので将来性が無いのかなーみたいな思っているの
で自分は畳は絶対にならないんですって言ってるんですけど
たたみかけるように
を絶対た旅の
需要が増えてた旅の時代が到来するから
絶対も more したりでもいいから注ぎなさいと言うんですけども全然落ちやる気
ないので
いやいや先生ちょっと待ってくださいよとって言ったんですけども万般クルーズよね
もう自分の倍以上で畳み掛けてくるんですよね
なので
もこれ困ったなあと思ういってあとまた
30分間のミーティングしかなかったので
これはどうするかなとめちゃくちゃ考えて
次の人のミーティングが入ってたので人の人の頭を下げてまで30分間
ちょっと延長またお願いしますって言って頭を下げて1時間にしてもらってずーっと
この畳はなりなさいなりたくないっていうのをずーっと家計早うしてまー方から見ると
どんな感じかっていう
川君なんか結構創造
をできたりできなかったりするかもしれないんですけどそういうのをずーっとやり取り
をして
けどやっぱ1時間じゃ足りなくてなのでやっぱ
まあ今日のミーティングでちょっと終わらそうかなんて思ってきて
わかりました先生なりますってことで一旦そこで終了して
で前世的にはもう納得したように笑顔で送り出してくれたんですけど自分は全然納得
いかず
けどまぁ色々とずーっと考えて最後に先生が言ったのが
た旅の歌をあなた作りなさいと
そしたら人のためにもなるから世の中の為にもなるからあなたはたた美容界がダメって
言うなら
その歌を作って盛り上げなさいと言ってくれたのがずーっと頭にあって
でずーっとまあ畳のヲタって何かなーと思って
今までは家族のうたとか友達の歌とか
ラブソングとか作ってたんですけど旅の歌ってなんか那覇とずっと考えて畳の桜
たーーー
まあ家業がた度や野犬何か作ってみようかなーみたいな
思ってで土とかおじいちゃんとか
畳はならないって言っているのでその2人には聞かずネットと品で熱海取ることを調べ
て
調べていっ曲作ってみましたそれでちょうど1週間後にライブが決まってたのでそこで
ちょっと歌ってみようかなと試しに歌ってみようかなということで作ってその曲を
披露したらめちゃくちゃ反応が良くてですね
はいもう
この曲が面白いとか
畳の歌でなんかちょっと笑顔になったとか子供も楽しみ寄ったとか打ったちょっと口ず
詰め寄ったみたいなことを言ったのでこれは人のためになるなぁと思って
なので今日はちょっと塗ってきましたのでよかったら引いてください
それでお願いします
pane
この合併
愛された旅
オッケー今日は赤いいただくた上で歌います
日本の旅は
奈良時代から受け機がれ今も人々に愛されていますうっ
あなたの家には
緑の場所にあります
1までいいから
me
飯バズーないじーっ
ところ家もはシスが少ないだ
ブービー失敗で失敗4パール紙工ます
キャラた破って3本分を持って
を知ってくれ
やーいい
画集とずっとずっとアジャジャン
大人まで愛された
7 a
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございますまあこのような感じでもうすごく
もう会場が沸い体これは畳の歌で人を喜ばせることができるんやったらこれは自分に
しか出来なと思ってはいそれから
次の畳の楽曲とかを作ってそれでもまた反応が良くてもうこれをで生きていこうと思っ
て父
またおじいちゃん言って畳は次ますって
やりました
ありがとうございますでそして次に挑戦なんですけど朝鮮っていうと中方ちょっと
難しかったりもするかもしれないんですけど自分は大きな挑戦があんまり出来なくて
どちらかというと小さな挑戦をたくさんやってますそれは何かというと
今日も見つけて
いるんですけど畳って書いた帽子とか
あとた旅のネクタイちょっと
楽屋にあるんですけど畳のバック後畳の財布
それを1ずつ
とものを増やしてってそして誰かにお会いした時に大
こんにちはと言うと熱海案とか面白いねーとか言われるのでそれであこれは人にウケる
んだっていうことを
小さな挑戦を繰り返して繰り返して大きな成功へと一歩一歩進んでいくようにしている
ので超
前っていうことはもう自分は大きな挑戦なく小さな挑戦を続けるようにしてます
そしてこの小さな挑戦をしていくと最近は
事務所が今ってお笑いのお笑いが強いエンタメの会社に所属をしたりとか
蒼樹そうやっていろんな挑戦をしていくことで掴むことができることもあるんだなーっ
て最近は実感しています
そして
自分次第で全ては変わると自分はずっと思ってます
他の人から頂いたアイディアでもやるかやらなく
以下で変わるし後
挑戦をするかしないかで変わってくるので自分次第で物事を考えていろいろと考えて
やると
すべて変わってくるんだなって
思ってずっとやってますなので皆さんも
他人から頂いたアイディアでもちいせーが変わるかもしれないので皆さん是非色々と
挑戦したりアイディアを自分のものにしたりして頑張っていただけたらなと思います
そして最後に自分の代表曲をあの
歌わせて終わりにしたいと思いますそれでは聴いてください
ta
emia
ホームページ今日はありがとうございましたつーか誰か search ラス編
手をたたいて
めちゃくちゃいい感じ
ban
[音楽]
ander paperbag こんにちはー
ブーバーレッスンまーっ
その後イベントお任せください火ダイアル交換日
愛を忘れて制限に100年以上続くストーリーそれが俺のバイフォーミー
[音楽]
karadana itani
消え pk バーイだー度をピーチティ nait
姫
ポケベチャっちゃいかん水で日下さ倍増です
ドライブ e ました味わいないそんな感じ
朝はない卒でもないだから+もいざファンディ
度は英語で書いても度世界第されるは違いない
俺がボットヒロベルゼイに仕掛けてー
[音楽]
ブーブーいい
dearheart anta dare ni paar たり二ティエー間パティ
エティ ni 経った日や遊びた databar アイターた率
ありがとうございましたパタミヤラバー fc た旅でした
またどこかで会い場所ありがとうございます